thank you very much my talk today is
based on joint work with svere rossen
who is a phd student in berkeley and
graduating
next spring
and we posted on
the article and archived about three
months ago
what direction should i
bring it at your own computer
okay
so the main problem is very simple
given some entries of a matrix is it
possible to add the missing entries such
that the matrix has rank one its entry
sum to one and it is non-negative
i will explain it the motivation for
this question in two slides so for
example
consider the partial matrix with four
diagonal entries and this has exactly
what it has a unique completion that has
rank one the entries are in a negative
and some to one
and
actually if i would perturb the diagonal
entries by a positive epsilon
then
the partial matrix wouldn't have a
completion anymore and if i would uh
protrude the interest by negative
epsilon then the matrix would have uh
infinitely many
desired completions
okay
so motivation for this question so the
question was uh communicated to us by
bernd sternfelds
but it was originally posed by two
statisticians
vicious carva and alexandra slavkovic
and
so it's related to independence modeling
statistics let x and y be two discrete
random variables with m and then states
respectively so this means that
probability that x is equal to i and y
is equal to j is equal to the product of
probabilities x is equal to i and y is
equal to j for all i and j
and
these joint
probabilities of x and y can be recorded
in a rank 1 matrix
so this is
um
that's the product of the probabilities
of x
and product of probabilities of y and
furthermore all the entries have to be
non-negative because probabilities are
not negative
and the entry sum to 1 because
all the probabilities of x and
probabilities of y sum to 1.
okay
and now
suppose that one knows only
some probabilities or only some
probabilities are measurable for example
this kind of situation could happen
when a pair of compounds in lab
reacts only when in certain
states
okay
and a complete answer to our question uh
would allow us to reject a hypothesis of
independence that x and y are
independent so if the matrix can't be
completed the rank one matrix and
um
okay
so let's start with a very easy example
a thai example
uh given a partial
matrix
um
with diagonal entries a and b
how to decide if this has a completion
we add
an extra entry x
and then the fourth entry is already
determined by two by two miners
because rank one means that the uh
the fourth entry needs to be a times b
divided by x and then we set the sum of
entries equal to 1
this is equivalent to a quadratic
equation
and
for this quadratic
equation to have a solution the
discriminant has to be non-negative
and together with the condition that a
plus b is less or equal than one this is
uh
sufficient to guarantee that x gives a
completion of m
and
these are exactly the shaded region
corresponds to a's and b's um
that
such that the diagonal two times two
diagonal partial matrix is completable
okay
um
result for
and
how our paper is structured first we
study diagonal partial matrices and then
we reduce all the other partial matrices
to the diagonal partial matrices and the
result for partial matrices is suppose
we have this partial matrix with
diagonal entries a1 to a n
and then m is completable if and only if
the sum of square roots of a i is less
or equal than one
so what what happens if you don't have
exactly n measurement so if you have
less than n is it always completable or
something um
greater than odds and smaller
so
if you have only
some parts of the
if you mean if you have only part of the
diagonal then you basically have the
same condition uh that you have to
consider that the sum of those and the
sum of uh square roots of those entries
is less or equal than one oh i see and
then you never have uniqueness but you
can still get a non-existent exactly
exactly actually and i think on the next
slide i have um a result about the
dimensions of
exactly and there is
there is a unique completion if and only
if the sum of square roots is equal to
one
and in fact so
if the sum of square roots is less than
one then if n is equal to two then the
probability matrix m has exactly two
completions and if n is greater than two
then the set of completions of m is n
minus two dimensional
minus two real dimensional
um
and minus two uh real-dimensional
the n-dimensional sphere
so
it's
so okay
i will show you this picture so
consider the three times three uh
partial
matrix with
the same element three same elements on
the diagonal
and i think for example this middle one
uh let's consider this curve this means
that we have diagonal entries at 110 110
110 on the diagonal and the set of
completions corresponds to this curve
and this curve is uh projected to the
um
sorry i haven't introduced u but you can
think that the matrix is a product of a
vector u and another vector v transposed
and this corresponds to the two first
coordinates of u
that it's a product
of the 1 9 is the point in the middle
a 1 9 is the point in the middle because
uh if you have 1 9 1 9 1 9 then the
unique completion is where you uh
all the entries of the matrix are 1 9.
and
remember we had our toy example so
this question was was it the if the set
is is at the top of the end is too
sphere
yes because it's simp it's basically um
it's a uh
inside it's basically it's homomorphic
the simplex
so it's uh homomorphic to that a sphere
yes sorry it's a homeopathic boundary of
simplex
and how does it relate to the die
example that we did so for the two times
two case
to get the inequalities in the first
example we need to square
this inequality twice and then we get
two inequalities the first inequality in
the positive orton corresponds to this
region and we need to add um
another inequality to cut out the
correct region of inequality uh
correct region of completions
and
now i get to the general partial
matrices i won't give you rituals or i
won't explain you
all the details but i rather try to
explain on an example
what happens how do we reduce to the
diagonal matrices so first
if you have a rower column of
where none of the entries is observed or
all the entries that are observed are
zeros then we just remove
those rows and columns
so we have removed the first row
now we use two times two minors to
fill up uh all the entries so if you
know more than we actually want to use
universal grammar basis of uh um
rank one determinant of variety but you
can also think uh we consecutively use
uh rank two minors until we can't
fill up
any further entries and we also check
that there is also no contradiction to
the rank one condition
okay so
then we get the block diagonal form
and next what we do
each block that we have we contract to
one element
so we contract all the columns and rows
corresponding to a block
and add up the corresponding entries in
the block so in this case
we have uh contracted this uh the first
two columns and the first two
rows to single row and single column and
we have added the elements of
this block and now it's in fact
in most of the cases there are a couple
of exceptions but i won't
explain
the exceptions
checking if this matrix is completable
is equivalent to checking if this
partial matrix is completable
and in fact it is because the
sum of square roots of these entries is
0.98 that's less than 1.
you some syrup
is
some of those four entries
i hope it's is it
okay
good
and the theorem for
general partial matrices say says that
let m be a feasible partial matrix by
feasible we mean that none of the
rank
one the drank one condition is already
not contradicted and also that we don't
have this kind of situation
where we have one zero one because this
would be also a contradiction um
we can
fill out the fourth entry
and
and such that after carefully removing
zeros it has s blocks and let bi be the
sum of the entries in the height block
after completing by two times two minus
our universal correct interfaces
um if s equals to one then m is
completable if and only if if b1 is
equal to 1 and if s is greater than 1
then we
get the same condition as for diagonal
partial matrices but now the bis are
actually the sum sums of entries in a
block
okay
and so another example suppose we have
this kind of probability matrix
with all observed entries non-negative
it has completion if and only if
if this
sum is less or equal than one so we have
filled out this entry and then used the
diagonal form
answers so the semester tensors are very
popular
um
we can't so for matrices we can we can
answer the question completely
for dancers things are more interesting
but we can we can understand we can
answer the question for diagonal
tensors suppose that uh
the observed entries in the dancers are
d i i dot dot i and all the other
entries are not observed
and the tensor is of order d so this
means it's two dimensions two times two
times two would be
an ordered tree tensor
and
then
the denser has a desired completion
uh if and only if the sum of these roots
of the observed entries is less or equal
than one so this is completable to a
rank one tensor with all entries uh
non-negative and entry summing to one
the same conditions
and this corresponds to
the
independent discrete random
variables um okay so this was about
conditions for completions
um
now partial tensors of fixed type
which can be completed to rank one
probability tensors form a semialgebraic
set this follows by tarsky zeitenberg
theorem
and
before we had
we had inequalities using a root it
would be also desirable to have uh
descriptions of the semi-algebraic sets
as poland combinations of polynomial
inequalities and equations
and what we can say
that there exists a unique irreducible
polynomial f of degree t to the n minus
one so d was order of the denser and n
was the
dimension in a dimension in one
degree
with constant term one that vanishes on
the boundary of diagonal partial
dentures which can be completed to rank
one
probability tensors and the same
algebraic description takes the form f
is greater or equal than zero all the
coordinates are greater equal than zero
plus additional inequalities that
separate our set from other chambers in
the region defined by greater equal than
zero so um if you're confused right now
there will be an example on the next
slide
um
yes i think so yes
so when d is two
it's two to the n minus one
it's two to the
uh n minus one
do you know that is that a familiar
polynomial
um
okay
let me get to the next slide
so
this is an example for three
three times three partial matrix with
abc diagonal entries
and this region is the same as
this inequality plus three these three
actually five inequalities where s1 s2
and s3 are symmetric uh polynomials
okay
and you can see here that this is a
degree 4 polynomial
so in this case
these two n is three
and constant term is one
and maybe it's enlightening to see this
let me okay remember this picture i will
go back to the previous slide
so
um
the previous la so the victory
corresponds to this region
and
we get in fact this region if you had
the five other inequalities
so this is similar that we had before
remember for two times two matrices
where there's region and we needed an
extra inequality
to cut out the desired region okay so
this was about the semi-algebraic sets
now i come to how to actually
find completions uh for
partial matrices
um
if you have only two blocks then the
situation is fairly easy
first
add in missing entries using two times
two minors
and
add in
a variable x
and fill out all the other entries using
two times two minors
now set the sum of variables equal to
one and solve for x
so in particular in this example
this yields uh two different completions
so for um
two
variables it's very uh relatively easy
now suppose we have
um
in blocks i'm really thinking of
diagonal matrix because um
the rest of the matrices can be um rest
or we can get the diagonal matrices
so
this is a completion of this diagonal
matrix is given by
a u
where t is a solution of this quadratic
system
and by you i mean again that our matrix
is u times a v transposed where u and v
are vectors
and um we derived this uh proposition
actually from the
proof
of uh
completing um diag
for checking if a
diagonal matrix has a complete uh
completion
and then another thing that we studied
is suppose we have a distance function
for example pearson chi squared distance
and i remember we had
a result about that there are
n minus two uh
or the solution set completion set is n
minus two dimensional maybe we want to
find the solution that minimizes a
distance function
and
this can be done using like uh lagrange
multipliers so this is another place
where we are solving a system of
polynomial equations so we solve the
lagrange multipliers um
for
uh for our polynomial for our
partial matrix and for example for this
matrix the minimum
is achieved at this matrix
and the pearson chi squared distance is
0.683
and now this is my last slide so
i'm on time
we could
characterize
diagonal tensors
the future work with sverosa and thomas
kala we want to understand a better
completion for dancers
we also could
completely characterize completions of
two times two times two dancers so most
of the cases
restrict are already cases that we know
or we can use flattenings of tensors and
then use completions of matrices to
answer the question for dancers and
there is one case
where we actually had to have to
add a variable x and then the
corresponding tensor is completable if
and only if the equation has a root in
interval zero uh
in the interval from zero to one and we
can also get um
we can get an equal inequality for this
using uh storm sequences uh but i'm not
getting into here and that's all
um last one is not basic
i don't know
i think it is i think we believe that
all of them uh i think we believe that
all of them are basically
but
but we started discussing something with
thomas carla um
using the implicit function theorem and
it seems that it might be that it's
basic and the important boundaries given
by
one equation but
this is all work uh our future work
yes i don't know what basic means and
that's what might be the same question
um do you know anything about the
topology of these slices
um
no
you knew one was the sphere
yes but this was for the matrices
so for dancers we don't know very much
almost nothing
okay
and that was my last slide and 22nd
minute have plenty of time for more
questions
you put up a chi-squared person from the
internet can you say what that means
um so this is just basically you can
think of this as a distance function so
here
we want to measure
or we want to find the completion of
this partial matrix that's
closest to the
uniform matrix with respect to the
pearson's chi-squared distance
but one can really choose any distance
function
so just sorry to repeat my question but
i mean these polynomials of degree two
to the n minus one they must be some
nice
sort of god-given symmetric functions
right
so this is really the positive origin of
the
one
of the unit ball with respect to the
norm uh 1d norm right and i would be
very very happy if the semi-algebraic
sets
of
these things are known oh actually okay
we actually do have the um
we do have the description of that
polynomial in our paper
so if you mean just uh one
so this is actually an hour of vapor
but i mean i'm not interested in a
formula but a kind of geometric
description like this is um
you know
polynomial that showed up somewhere
before or something as
characterizing this metric function
yeah
it's got to be some nice symmetric
polynomial right
can i show you the polynomial after the
talk
assumption on the okay when it becomes
easy
um
if
i think it gets
i think it gets easy
do you find any matrices which have
finitely many completions but more than
one
yes so if you have a two times two
diagonal matrix then um
and if the sum of
and if the sum of the
square roots of diagonal entries entries
is less than one then you always have
two completions
okay
so so we have one example for rank two
in our paper uh rank two three times
three matrices and seven variables
observed that's the best that we can do
more questions